F3: One of the biggest impediments to getting
things done in the United States Senate when
you have a majority but not a 60 seat majority, is
to filibuster. And the filibuster is a mechanism
through which even if you only need 50 votes to
pass something, you need 60 votes to end debate
on that very issue and move to the votes.
M1: And this is a mechanism that allows a party
in the minority to indefinitely hold up voting on
legislation and to obstruct and to do all of the
things that Republicans led by Mitch McConnell,
love to do to Democrats. Now, Democrats could blow
up the filibuster completely. This is called the
nuclear option. And we've talked about it before.
But it is a double edged sword.
F3: And it could, as I've
talked to you before about it, could come back to
really bite Democrats when Republicans are back
in the majority at some point in the future. This
has been a point of contention about which there
are reasonable positions on both sides. But in an
interview with ABC News that aired last night, Joe
Biden told George Stephanopoulos he does support
reforming the Senate filibuster, not eliminating
it with the nuclear option, but reforming it.
Well, what exactly is the reform that Joe Biden
is interested in? Let's take a look at the clip.
M5: So aren't you going to have to choose?
I know you've been reluctant to do away with
the filibuster. Aren't you gonna have to choose
between preserving the filibuster and advancing
your agenda? Yes, but here's the choice. I don't
think you have to eliminate the filibuster.
You have to do it. What it used to be when I
first got to the Senate and back in the old days
when you used to be around there and that is in
a filibuster, you had to stand up and command
the floor and you had to keep talking alone.
You couldn't call for, you know, no one could
say in a quorum call once you stop talking. You
lost that. And someone could move in and say,
I moved the question of. So you had to work for
the filibuster. So you're for that reform. You're
for bringing back the talking filibuster. I am.
That's what it was supposed to be. Look, I think
don't hold me to the numbers, George, but I think
between 1960 and 2000 and I'm making this number
up, I don't know. There are like, you know,
50 filibusters now. They're like two hundred sense
that since just put a hold on it. That's it. Yeah.
I mean, you know, so the idea is almost is getting
to the point where there's no democracies having a
hard time functioning, a hard time functioning.
M1: Now this is notable for a few reasons. Now,
just a couple of days ago, Joe
Biden's press secretary, Jen Psaki,
was asked about the filibuster during a press
briefing and she said Joe Biden does not want
to change any rules on the filibuster.
F3: So that seems to have changed. But
more importantly, on substance, Biden
doesn't say get rid of the filibuster,
just make it more difficult by requiring
an actual talking filibuster. And this
is an important detail to understand right now.
Senators can indefinitely extend debate on a topic
and prevent voting on that topic by asking to
extend debate period and just never allowing
debate to end. When someone moves to end debate
and vote, Republicans can say, no, I want to
extend debate and they're able to do it. In the
past, senators actually had to hold the floor
and speak and keep speaking to delay a bill. And
the idea that Joe Biden is suggesting and others
have also mentioned is to require the actual
speaking to take place so senators can't just
ask for an extension and then another one and
then another one. They actually have to talk
through the filibuster. And this would have
two effects. First of all, it would require
Republicans to actually organize, to have
back to back to back speakers in the Senate,
never ending with their 50 senators. They actually
would be able to do it. But how long will they be
willing to do it from a practical standpoint,
24/7, day after day after day, but maybe more
importantly, a talking filibuster that goes on
and on and on merely to prevent a vote on an
issue is going to pick up media attention the
longer it goes. And presumably it will come off
as exactly the type of blatant obstruction that
it is. Now, the possible political miscalculation
is that we're assuming the current Republican
Party would be mad about that and they would
say this must end, let's just have a vote. But the
current Republican Party has been so propagandized
that they might not actually be that mad about an
endless talking filibuster. They might like it.
But the gamble is that the left and the centrists
and maybe some Republicans would say, guys, we
we don't have control of the Senate. This isn't
really Democratic. This has to end. You have to
put the issue to a vote. Maybe that is what
it what what would happen? I don't know. Now,
why does this matter? Bigger picture. It matters
because. Filibuster rules in the next two years
might actually determine does Washington, D.C.
become a state, does Puerto Rico become a state?
Does automatic voter registration get passed? And
a whole bunch of other important issues? This is
not trivial. And the point is that right now it's
too easy to filibuster with very little work and
without much political cost. Now, there's a couple
of other ideas that have been floated. One, this
is not what Biden supports, but these are other
ideas to affect the filibuster without ending it.
One idea is you have to have 40 senators present
to extend the filibuster. Right now. It's if you
don't have 60, you can't end debate. The idea is
to flip the onus and put it on Republicans to keep
having 40 of their 50 senators in the chamber, 24
seven to continue extending the filibuster. That
would be a very good idea without blowing it up.
The other thing is that the talking filibuster,
it should have to be relevant to the topic at
hand. In other words, if you are trying to end
debate on automatic voter registration and go to a
vote. You can't get up there and read a Dr. Seuss
book to filibuster, you should be filibustering
materially with something connected to automatic
voter registration, and that's another possibility
that could be done. We will see. This is a really
big deal. And, you know, it's one of these
things where a lot of this stuff like, oh,
Joe, when is Joe Biden going to do his first press
conference? Sort of like, you know, it's an inside
the Beltway story that also has very little impact
on Americans. The filibuster is something a lot of
people are not following and aren't aware of, but
it actually does relate to things that would have
a very direct and serious impact on Americans
in terms of what it would allow the Senate to
do. So we're going to continue following. Now,
this is this is Joe Biden's latest view on this
issue. Let's now talk about the flip side of the
coin, which is Mitch McConnell's view on the issue